hope and change turns out to be discord
and confusion I'm and there's no way
that you can stop that you cannot stop
the blunders of one government program
by putting another one on top hi I'm
Nicholas before recent TV today we're
talking with Richard Epstein the law
professor at NYU Chicago and affiliated
with the Hoover Institution we're nearly
two years into Obama's presidency and
he's managed so far to post an even
worse record than George Bush the
economy's lost 3.3 million jobs consumer
confidence is at half of its historical
average unemployment over 9% and has
been that way for a well over a year to
what extent is Obama responsible for
this well I think certainly added
another nail into the coffin at least
the early George Bush and Obama have a
lot in common the difference between
them which is why Obama's the more
dangerous man ultimately is he has very
little by way of a skill set to
understand the kinds of complex problems
that he wants to address but he has this
unbounded confidence in himself he's the
perfect Chicago faculty no he wasn't on
the faculty I know he was actually a
very bad Chicago faculty member in this
sense to the extent that he was an
adjunct we had always hoped that he
would participate in the general
intellectual discourse but he was always
so busy with collateral adventures that
he essentially kept to himself and the
problem when you keep to yourself is you
don't get to hear strong ideas
articulated by people who disagree with
you did you encounter him at all or what
yeah what kinds of interactions to Jeff
um usually in the breezeway because he
was always running and gunning for some
other kinds of things um I also knew him
because his next my next-door neighbor
is one of his best friends probably his
best friend named Martinez but and I
would see him there a speak about him
and he was all I think in many kinds of
cases I'm always in tremendously
engaging in charming individuals but
he's not the kind of guy who likes to be
pushed and so what he does in effect is
he has a way of listening to you to make
it appear as though you're the only
person in the world who matters and then
when it's all done he said now what does
he believe he's amazingly good at
playing sort of intellectual poker but
that's actually a disadvantage because
we don't put your ideas out there to be
shot down you're never going to figure
out what kind of revision you want and
what is characteristic his temperament
of
right now is he's basically set in
concrete if he thought of stimulus would
work in 2009 he thinks it today let's
talk about the stimulus critics say it's
like taking one bucket of water from you
know an end of the pool or a cesspool
and dumping it in the other it doesn't
get you anywhere are there any surprises
with stimulus spending no I mean I think
only the following when you run these
stimulus programs you tend to use models
of consumer behavior that work in good
times but there's no guarantee that
they'll work in bad times so the idea
was that you put more money into the
pockets of middle and lower-income class
people you get higher levels of
consumption it hasn't worked out that
way
why should it work out the way these
people have consumer debts they're
behind in their mortgages they want to
save for colleges they will save their
change their strategies as they see the
world of opportunity shrink so they'll
save more and invest and spend less with
tax cuts have stimulated the economy
permanent tax cuts will have that effect
and a flattening of the tax rates I mean
the old Adam Smith adages correct low
and easy and reliable taxation is what
commits people to long term investments
if you give a short term cut with a
gimmick then people are gonna worry
about what about next year what about
people like David Stockman it was
Reagan's budget director who says that
given the huge amounts of federal debt
and deficit that extending the Bush tax
rates forward at any level as a problem
does that make sense or I think the
problem about the political economy of
David Stockman is he doesn't realize
that increased revenues don't go to
discharge debts they go to create new
debts and so I have no confidence in
that proposal what you need to do is to
take a pick ax or a ham or some very
large tool and cut out huge numbers of
government programs what we're doing at
the bottom what's the first government
program that should well I mean you know
it's difficult to know but your
agricultural subsidies and import
barriers is certainly a very obvious
place in which to start knock out
something like ethanol certainly you
wanted to go massive liberalisation with
respect to labor markets you don't want
to have strong civil rights laws which
only come things up you want to get rid
of the Family Medical Leave Act and so
forth you want to know the minimum what
if what about entitlements Medicare is a
very hard thing to deal with because you
create all these expectations for people
who are in midstream
what I would like to see done under that
is to increase the co-pays and to try to
read and and reduce the time at which
you're in the program by raising the
eligibility under these things and the
same thing with Social Security should
there be means-tested then you increase
the level of income redistribution
that's going to take place in society
you get more high marginal taxes on your
most productive individuals and what you
gain in the savings under the Medicare
program you are likely to lose in
overall terms of productivity I'm just
basically a strong flat tax guy because
I don't think an economy runs as well
when you have all these pits and valleys
inside the operation and you just have
to cut back what aspects of President
Obama's health care bill do you think
will be most detrimental to patients
well I think the whole thing in many
cases will be so because of the constant
intrusion of third-party providers ie
the government in the physician patient
relationships the one area that's
causing the greatest short-term problem
is to try to figure out what you do with
these medical loss ratios with respect
to private plans because what happened
is the Democrats in Congress with some
Republican acquiesced and said we know
that the reason why things are too
expensive is that while god there's too
much waste in the system competition
doesn't control costs so they mandate
price controls it's gonna be just like
rent control the only way you could meet
the price control requirements are in
effect to reduce the quality of the
services what's the outlook for the
legal challenge to Obamacare well it's
actually better than one had thought
then and there are two kinds of
challenges that could be made a one of
those is facial challenge on the medical
mandate and when the case was brought in
and that's the coverage mandate that
everybody has to win $2,000 if you don't
get these plans Randy Barnett for
example helped organize this did a very
clever job of advocacy for two reasons
one is he dreamed up an argument which
didn't threaten Social Security and
Medicare with constitutional extinction
and secondly he gave a relatively clear
line so now it's the government who has
to face the slippery slope problem if
you could force us to buy $2,000 because
there's a coordination problem and a
free rider problem
why can't you force us to brush our
teeth three times a day to have certain
kinds of balanced diets do exercise and
it turns out you get yourself a
totalitarian state so it was a peculiar
mixture of libertarian sentiments with
jurisdictional issues it was very well
done
what do you think the odds are the legal
challenge working to invalidate
Obamacare 20% I would say 25 but this is
up from 5 to 10% but I do think is that
as the politics become more
controversial and the unpopularity of
the plan
becomes more evident the willingness of
judges to entertain novel arguments will
increase and therefore the odds will
start to move up let's talk about
financial reform in July Obama signed
the dodd-frank financial reform act well
this bill make good on claims that it'll
simplify consumer credit markets and
inoculate us from bank bailout well let
me start with the consumer credit
markets I am now one of the lawyers
working for a bank called TCF which is
old twin city federal bank and we filed
suit in South Dakota trying to declare
this statute unconstitutional insofar as
the Durbin amendment specifies in very
precise detail amount of money that is
collected that the retailer has to pay
to the visa for processing the stuff its
own bank for processing the thing and
most importantly for the banks that
issue the debit cards to maintain their
very extensive network and essentially
what happens in our case to give you the
numbers is right now on a typical $35
debit card transactions TCF Bank gets 37
cents by the 47 cents excuse me when
you're done with looking at the numbers
under this particular statute that
numbers down to 7 cents so there's a 40%
loss the theory of the statute is well
just raise your rates to your customers
as if you could do that but
unfortunately all banks with under 10
billion dollars in assets are exempt
from the statute we know what the market
looks like you raise your rates you will
lose your customers in droves so we are
basically between a rock and a hard
place and the challenge is take the
price restrictions on the one hand and
the alternatives of unregulated firms on
the other and you have a confiscatory
regulatory scheme and we filed that case
I actually think it's a pretty solid
case ah it's unlike the health care
situation these costs are very carefully
analyzed and so forth the program is
certainly going to create absolute chaos
inside the market and everybody knows
that and I think the constitutional
challenges will win I don't think that
constitutional challenges are likely to
win to the two-tier stuff that you see
with respect to the rest of dodd-frank
big banks that are too failed
too big to fail going in one area it
would definitely won't inoculate us from
I mean these banks are insanely launched
it just give you a perspective
TCF is a pretty big Bank they have 18 18
billion dollars in assets a real company
yeah Chase has 100
times that size it's 1.8 trillion
dollars is something the left hand does
not know what the right hand is doing
and the third feature is Senator Dodd
came here and spoke at NYU and somebody
asked him what about Fannie and Freddie
so we couldn't tackle it at this point
well that's obviously the biggest source
of problems that we have and if that
content hours aren't the biggest because
what happens is these people are
completely irresponsible in the way in
which they issue and guarantee loans so
what they do is they put more crap
holder into the market you get cheap
mortgages and what you do is you bit up
the high price of assets and then you
wait for the crash to come and you'll
get more default in fact one of the
terrible things in the Obama
administration is they will not let
quote-unquote nature take its course by
constantly trying to fend off
foreclosures which means that the market
never clears these properties are held
in overhang and people could actually
afford to buy them at market prices are
excluded from the market on this issue
they get themselves a straight effort
what are policies that Congress and the
president could have gotten behind that
would prevent massive violence well for
one thing is make it very clear that we
don't guarantee you in the event of loss
and that if can't the parties want
protection they better get it either
from their trading partners or third
party by way of situation because the
tougher you are at the beginning the
less likely it is that you're going to
have these kinds of situations and you
won't get the mad scramble where an AIG
bailout essentially works for the
benefit of goldman sachs who's by far
the shrewdest player in all of this
stuff the more solid the market depends
upon having large numbers of
intermediate sized player so you know
something might be being PT Bank is what
it's about 150 billion dollars worth of
assets that's plenty big to do virtually
any transaction that you need but it's
not going to create systemic risk the
real systemic risk that you create is
having five major banks which were monks
them have you know ten trillion dollars
worth of assets floating around in their
coffers and you ask what I would do more
generally the basic mechanism is mutual
gains through trade every regulation
basically has to be justified because
the moment it limits gains from trade
you have to explain why it's needed and
these guys impose these regulations like
they're candy going down the throat of a
two-year-old it's just a sweet we better
do more of it in the large sense of
shifting from a rule by kind of
aristocratic Fiat or monarchic Oh fiat
to govern
of rules that's an old shift from a kind
of feudal mentality to a republican when
small our Republican what do you do to
spread that and make that more
persuasive or you simply and I think
that's the message you get in this
election you show people that all the
ingenuity of gimmicks fails and you gave
the figures at the beginning we have
more debt more unemployment and less
happiness in this country now because
hope and change turns out to be discord
and confusion I'm and there's no way
that you can stop that you cannot stop
the blunders of one government program
by putting another one on top of it
that's what I learned in the air war
school you know like what the minimum
wage does you create a welfare program
you don't like what a welfare program
does have it back to work program if you
just got rid of the minimum wage you get
rid of three programs and you free up
lots of economies and what people have
to understand is that Mies van der Rohe
was essentially a political theorist
when he said more less is more I mean
you get more production out of fewer
regulations and one of the great
tragedies of the modern stuff is they
spent all this time on monetary and
fiscal policy where regulatory policy
taken in the round and taking in
particular cases is in fact every bit as
important of mine asked me to ask you
how do you sleep at night let me put it
this way I don't stay awake because of a
guilty conscience well thank you Richard
really wonderful thanks
[Music]